hold on elaborate on this some more
because okay jails for bad people these
people are in jail they must be bad what
are you doing I mean representing uh is
their label on them if they're - I don't
know really much of anything about it
except but you you actually brought it
to my attention
fill us in because someone says what do
you represent terrorists for what what's
going on with this and his daughter
needed surgery just to live and she
agree was able to find a charity who
funded his daughter's surgery but shukri
said that changed his life he said I am
a Muslim and I love to give so he left
his job he quit he founded a charity he
put his heart and soul into a charity
that grew to be the largest Muslim
charity in the United States they were
mainly giving humanitarian aid to
Palestinians in the West Bank and Gaza
as well as the refugee populations in
Lebanon and Jordan and then they also
gave to other needy populations across
the world what was going on in this
country was a charitable activity one
that is protected by our Constitution
one that I believe the five people that
have been subject to this trial are not
guilty of committing any crime but had
been persecuted because of where they
are in history it's a political
situation this was a political trial as
far as I'm concerned as far as a lot of
other civil liberties organizations are
concerned
my name is Edward Abington I'm a former
American diplomat I third spent thirty
years dealing mainly with the Middle
East specifically arab-israeli issues
my last overseas assignment was as the
American Consul General in Jerusalem
from 1993 to 1997
we never received any warnings or
caution about dealing with the Holy Land
Foundation they were considered to be a
legitimate American charity and I was
familiar with the work with their work
they had a good reputation for honesty
and providing assistance to the people
who really needed it but it's a law
certainly in the last year since 9/11
has been aimed particularly at Muslims
and not just charities about Muslims who
have any relationship at all with groups
that the u.s. designates as terrorist
now what's interesting is there's a cop
groups we talk talked about in the Holy
Land five case those were not designated
as terrorists you would think that if
there were really front groups for Hamas
that the US would have designated but
they didn't it just shows what a really
made-up clinical persecution this was
the United States has never labeled
zakat committees as controlled by Hamas
or as being a terrorist organizations
and in fact up until 2007-2008 a I D was
channeling assistance through American
NGOs working with zakat committees so
the allegation that the Israelis made
that these organizations were basically
controlled with Hamas was certainly not
the view of the United States government
at the time I was serving in Jerusalem
or for that matter afterwards and that
was very contradictory I mean it was
like the left hand doesn't know what the
right hand was doing as far as I'm
concerned they're just like many other
people that had been unjustly jailed for
their political activities defense was
trying to say look the Justice
Department is alleging that the Holy
Land Foundation is supporting terrorism
because they're working with zakat
committees but we have a long list of
projects funded by the US government
working with American NGOs who worked
with zakat committees and we have the
documentation to show this the the court
kept a lot of that documentation out of
the try
these defendants particularly fitness or
giving money to the zakat committees
knowing that was going to Hamas whether
it's legitimate or not really isn't at
issue
it's whether they knew that the money
that was being funneled to the
committee's were actually going to Hamas
and I think we established that at trial
but the United States government was
also giving money to a zakat committee
yeah you know I don't remember that it's
being that you know it's been a long
time at a minimum you shouldn't be
prosecuted for providing Geritol
activity to a group that has not even
been put on a list so that you have
noticed that you're not supposed to be
aiding it I mean they checked the list
they they the the board of HLF could
check the list and they would say okay
here's the groups that are on the list
we're not going to support any of those
here's groups that are not on the list
we can support those there's a case that
I'm writing about right now in the
United States which is called the case
of the Holy Land Foundation there's been
persecution and prosecutions of
Palestinians Arabs and Muslims in
America and all over the West actually
for a very long time now I'm sure you've
all heard the term Islamophobia
now we're not again talking to some
laymen this is my friend my co-pilot the
general son father was a general in the
Israeli army great-great-great
grandfather grandfather one of the
original signers of the Declaration of
Independence we got an expert in this
area the case of the Holy Land
Foundation is a fund is a foundational
case the Holy Land Foundation in United
States was the largest Muslim charity in
America and it was run by Palestinians
their focus was Palestine but they gave
her Libre they offered relief after 9/11
after the Oklahoma City bombings in
floods and earthquakes not only in the
US but all around the world in Turkey
and other places and of course
tremendous relief they were able to
offer in Palestine helping the poorest
of the poor and wonderful people and
great friends like you and I have been
speaking to their lawyers and I've never
seen lawyers cry as much as the lawyers
who represent these these men the
frustration where the defense case is so
strong the prosecution's case is so weak
yet the prosecution wins time and time
appeal after appeal after appeal you
know about the case of the whole Latin
foundation that I've been but I'm
writing about right now the books had
come out next year and I visited Supriya
but care and we filled up the car there
and have a Brahim amazeen
and I've got about all day I'm visited
all of them in prison federal prison
here in the United States
none of them are oppressed none of them
are prisoners I mean even though there's
they're in federal prison for very very
long sentences they're all free men and
they speak like free men and their
spirit is strong and and so I don't feel
like I speak for the oppressed I feel
like I'm speaking for friends of mine
who are living in very harsh conditions
that have been imposed on them and
that's terrible injustice so I'm
speaking for that remedy dad to correct
the injustice and it's a very rewarding
experience
hold on elaborate on this some more
because okay jails for bad people these
people are in jail they must be bad what
are you doing I mean representing is
their label on them if they're I don't
know really much of anything about it
except but you you actually brought it
to my attention
fill us in because someone says what do
you represent terrorists for what what's
going on with this well the case of the
hardline foundation Berlin Foundation
was the largest Muslim charity in
America at one time and then in December
of 2001 after 9/11 President George Bush
closed them down with an executive order
claiming that they were financed Network
for Hamas for terrorism
so this raises several issues number one
how does that happen how did how do you
take a charity organization and suddenly
conflated with it with with supporting
terrorism how do you criminalize charity
you know it takes some ingenuity some
creativity and how do you label five men
good men who did nothing wrong in fact
did everything right and everything good
and suddenly label them terrorists to
throw them in federal prison for very
very long for many many years and this
has to do with with the narrative that
Australians are terrorists the charity
the Palestinian me Palestinians means
you're encouraging terrorism the claim
was that they gave what is called
material support to a terrorist
organization by working with zakat
committees in Palestine and since the
prosecution could never prove that a
single penny from homeland foundation
actually went to any terrorist
organization or any organization that is
what is called recognized or as or
designated as a terrorist organization
they claimed that the organized the CAD
committees in Palestine are part of
Hamas which is not true now every other
organization around the world that
provides relief for Palestine works with
the cot committees the only place the
only organization that was that was
actually accused of supporting terrorism
by working with these committees is the
whole land foundation case in the trial
took place in the Northern District of
Texas everywhere else in the world and
everywhere else here in the United
States US aid and the State Department
and so on still work with the
committee's and of course none of those
academies were ever designated as
terrorist organizations quite the
opposite so hold on foundation five did
nothing wrong
they wouldn't support they wouldn't
support terrorism anyway because these
are good people they wouldn't support
violence anyway they are Palestinian
Patriots
they did what they believed was the
right thing to do and I believe was the
right thing to do which is support
they're there they're there their
brothers and sisters in their homeland
in Palestine but they had to be brought
down because the narrative is that
Palestinians are terrorists the
narrative is that these realities are
victims and the Palestinians are the
perpetrators of violence and so having a
good kind face to Palestinian charity
doesn't work and so they had to be taken
down and I believe it's a completely
political case it was a terrible
injustice they did nothing wrong they
are not terrorists I think they're
probably more people in prison that
don't deserve to be in prison than most
people know but in the case of these
five people there's actually no doubt I
think in anybody's mind that they are
completely innocent and they were put in
this position only because this is a
political trial so I've been visiting
them and meeting with them and meeting
with the families and I met people who
worked with them in Palestine and I met
and I went to visit their homes in
Palestine
and like I said the book is coming out
all being well next year they will tell
this terrible story of this injustice
before I go into another question
you must have obviously I mean you
wouldn't end up putting your name on
something if you didn't really believe
in the product for example in this case
you wouldn't stand behind certain
individuals if they were terrorists I
don't know I mean unless somebody's
crazy deranged you know other mind but
you obviously must have done your
homework you must have really I mean
looked into this before you started
visiting someone in jail and then
writing a book and so you're obviously
well I mean very well informed in this
era and how much does a person have to
dig in this area to see that you know
there's some injustice going on or a lot
of injustice well actually you don't
have to dig very far it's it's it's it's
crystal clear
it doesn't take it doesn't take a lot to
realize that to see that this was an
injustice it doesn't take a lot actually
to see that there was that these people
were that this whole trial was
politically motivated that this whole
trial was put together this whole
accusation and closing over the whole
that foundation and the prosecution of
these five men was politically motivated
it doesn't really take much the way the
trial was conducted the kind of evidence
that was allowed to be brought in which
was completely unacceptable and
irrelevant
and so it actually doesn't take much I
did do my homework I have been
researching this for almost four years
now I've read thousands and thousands
and thousands of pages of court
documents and spoke to lawyers and then
read the appeals and read the opinions
of both you know both sides and like I
said I visited the people in prison I
visited their families I visited people
in Palestine who worked with them I know
the things that they did I've seen the
projects and there's no question in my
mind that these men are innocent men
and that their sentence should be at
least commuted if not if not completely
exonerated dear mr. president I have
been writing the letter to year after
year I'm 11 years old now I am one of
the proud daughters of the Holy Land
five my father and four other great men
were put into jail for nothing my father
got 65 years he did not hurt anyone or
anything if anything he helped people
now the favor I really want from you is
to feed the hl5 you are the only one who
can do this and I hope you will did you
know I have the same birthday as dr.
Martin Luther King jr. maybe that's how
he seems the same come on mr. president
we need you can you solve this case I
hope you think about this and please as
soon as you can thank you sincerely an
American girl who wants her dad back